we're on problem 39 and it says which
ordered pairs the vertex of f of X is
equal to x squared plus 6x plus 5 now
finding vertex is of Prowers there's a
formula and you know negative B over 2a
but you might forget that when you turn
30 years old and the whole goal of this
isn't just to pass an algebra exam is to
learn algebra and then when you learn
calculus you learn actually a much
easier way to figure out minimum and
maximum points but there's actually an
intuitive way of doing it in and out in
algebra as well what we have to do is
just write this in that form where we
have it let's see we can write it in if
we could write this function if we could
write it in the form like this f of X is
equal to a times X plus or minus
something I don't know B squared plus C
then we know the vertex happens when X
is equal to B right because if you look
at this form of a parabola and you can
write any of these in this form then you
say okay this term right here is always
going to be positive so the minimum
point of this parabola is when this term
is equal to 0 and then the minimum point
of this term happens when X is equal to
B when this term is equal to zero right
and so the vertex becomes X B comma C so
let's do that with this and you could
memorize it I mean it's it ends up being
minus B over 2a but let's just actually
solve it because I want you to have the
intuition f of X is equal to x squared
plus 6x plus 5 and I wrote a gap there
for a reason because we're essentially
going to complete a square we want to
turn this x squared plus 6s plus
something into a perfect square and
you've hopefully have some practice
completing the square
what what number is half of six because
when we when we square it when we get if
we do X plus a squared that equals what
x squared plus 2ax plus a squared so if
we map that to that x squared is x
squared right - ax is equal to 6 so a
would be equal to 3 and if a is equal to
3 a squared would be equal to 9 and when
you can't just add an
to one side of equation you can either
have to do to both sides or you have to
do something to offset that so if we
added a nine here if we added a nine
here let's just subtract a 9 as well
right so then we get x squared plus 6x
plus 9 plus 5 minus 9 so this right here
this part of it that's equal to X plus 3
squared and then this part 5 minus 9
minus 4 and there we got it into our
format that we needed so when does this
function achieve a minimum point well it
Jeeves a minimum point when this part is
equal to 0 or when X is equal to minus 3
and when X is equal to minus 3 this is 0
so f of X is going to be equal to minus
4 so that's the vertex and that's choice
a and you could have done minus B over
2a you'd get minus 12 over - no - B no
minus 6 over 2 which is minus 3 that's
something you could memorize but it's
better I think to have the intuition
problem 40 the graph of alright the
graph of X my x over 2 squared minus y
over 2 squared equals 1 is a hyperbola
and that makes sense if this was this is
y over 3 x over 2 squared minus y over 3
squared is equal to 1 if this was a plus
we would have an ellipse fair enough
which set of equations represents the
asymptotes of the hyperbola graph and
once again there are some equations that
people memorize some formulas people
memorize but you can actually have an
intuition on this so let's think about
what happens as X approaches positive or
negative infinity because that's what
that's what we care about it as an
asymptote right what what is the graph
approach when we get two really really
large values of X and it turns out
really large values of Y so let's just
rearrange this a little bit let's I
almost put Y on the other side so we get
let's square this so this is x squared
over 4
or I'll let me let me keep it actually
in that format let's keep that is x over
two squared is equal to one plus y over
three squared let's subtract one from
both sides so you get x over two squared
minus one is equal to Y over three
squared and now let's multiply both
sides by three squared right or let's
multiply both sides by nine right let's
do that actually let me let me just just
simplify this let me rewrite this I
wanted to keep it in that form but let
me just that's the same thing as x
squared over four minus one is equal to
Y squared over nine multiply both sides
by nine and I'm gonna switch the side so
we get Y here so you get Y squared is
equal to nine over four x squared minus
nine alright and that's about as far as
we can get just with straight up algebra
but when we think about asymptotes those
are points that the graphs will never
reach but it'll get close to so we have
to think about what happens when X gets
really large and and correspondingly Y
gets really large well as X gets really
large so as X approaches infinity and
you learn this in precalculus and
calculus these are limits but it's
really a very intuitive concept X as X
gets really large this minus 9 doesn't
matter much this term starts to dominate
it right these terms matter a lot more
than this minus 9 so as X approaches
infinity Y squared is approximately
equal to 9/4 x squared and now we could
take the square root of both sides of
this so you get Y is approximately equal
to plus or minus 3 halves X and those
are the actual asymptotes y equals 3
halves X and Y is equal to minus 3
halves X and that's actually choice a
and well I won't go into the actual
instruction of how you would think about
graphing actually why not why don't we
just do that we know what the asymptotes
are let's actually think about how you
would graph this so if you were to draw
the it's all about learning not just
about assessing if I were to that's the
X and y axis
and they they tell us our asymptotes
three halves X and minus three halves X
so 3 halves X that's the slope of three
halves is one point five so it's a it's
a slope that would look something like
we get the line tool out so plus three
halves X might look X would look like
that so plus three half X would look
something like that and minus three
halves X would be something like that
and now we have to figure out does is
this is this high part is does this
hyperbola go from there and there or
does it go from here and here and there
we just say okay does it have a see when
Y is equal to zero right when Y is equal
to zero we get x over two is equal to
plus or minus one right x over two is
equal to plus or minus one so you could
say x squared right so you would you
actually get X would be there so X is
plus or minus two so you know that they
this thing has x-intercepts you can set
Y is equal to zero you can't set X is
equal to zero if you get X is equal to
zero then you get minus you know Y
squared is equal to sum' so you get Y
squared equals negative want to get some
imaginary solution so you know that it
has x-intercepts and you know that these
are the asymptotes so if you wanted to
draw the graph that looks something like
that I know that's not a great drawing
but hopefully it serves the purpose
anyway the choice was a and hopefully
you learned a little bit about
asymptotes next problem 41 which of the
following represents a hyperbola let me
copy those know which represents a
parabola they want to know that's too
small I don't think you can see that get
a bigger version of it
all right that's a bigger version there
you go which of these represents a
parabola well we could just go one by
one this is a circle right that's a
circle then you could graph you like
this isn't ellipse right where you just
kind of wait the Y's and the X Squared's
a little bit is an ellipse if this was a
negative this would be a hyperbola
ellipse this one's a hyperbola cause you
have this negative here hyperbola now
this one might not look like a
traditional parabola but it really is
right because if I were to divide both
sides of this by 4p I get X is equal to
1 over 4p times y squared so it's a
sideways parabola right it looks
something like this if that's the x and
y axis the graph will look something
like this it's going to be a sideways
problem but it's a parabola nonetheless
so the choice is C choice is C I think I
have time for at least one more problem
42 they give the following equation
paste it here all right and they say
what is the standard form of the
equation of the conic section above and
essentially they wanted to they want us
to complete the square with the X's and
the y so we get that you know X minus
something squared over some constant you
know plus or minus y minus something
squared over some constant so let's do
that
so let's group the X in the Y term so
you get 4x squared minus 16x plus
something right that's how we're going
to complete the square and then you get
plus you get minus 5y squared so let me
just - and I'll do plus 5y squared and
then we have a minus here so it becomes
plus 30 y plus 30 Y and then you have a
out here you have a minus 9 is equal to
0 and just to simplify it let's factor a
4 out of this part so you get 4 times x
squared minus 4x plus something - let's
factor 5 out 5 times y squared plus 6y
probably plus something now let's add
the 9 to both sides is equal to 9 all
right so let's think about it if we
wanted to complete the square here what
do we
put here to make this a perfect square
well for this was a plus for that this
would be X minus 2 squared right so
we're adding a 4 here right but we're
really adding a 4 times before we're
really adding a 16 if you think about it
if I were to redistribute this I just
added 16 right so if I had 16 to one
side of equation I have to add 16 to the
other side of the equation so that's 16
there and to make this a perfect square
let's see half of 6 is 3 so 3 squared is
9 so if I don't 9 here but I'm really
adding a 5 times a 9 right I could
redistribute the 5 I really added a 45 I
did it to one side of the equation
oh no I did a minus 5 times 9 no I got I
caught myself I added a minus 5 times 9
so I'm really subtracting 45 from that
side stuff to subtract 45 from that side
and so this simplifies to 4 times X
minus 2 squared right that's X minus 2
squared minus 5 x this is y plus 3
squared y plus 3 squared is equal to
let's see 9 plus 16 is 25 25 minus 45
let's see if I made a mistake someplace
25 minus 45 no that's right 20 25 minus
45 is minus 20 right and now we can
divide both sides by minus 20 if I did
this correctly
all right well divide both sides by
minus 20 and so you get X minus 2
squared and what's 4 divided by minus 20
it's minus 1 fit let me just do that so
4 over minus 20 minus 5 times y plus 3
squared over minus 20 is equal to 1 and
so this is equal to let's see this
becomes a positive and this one becomes
a negative so let's put this one first
so 5 over 20 is the same thing as y plus
3 squared over 4 all right that's this
one plus no sorry we have a minus minus
and this becomes 1/5 X minus 2 squared
or
five and that is equal to one and that
we haven't made a careless mistake that
is choice B see you in the next video